il y a du moment hein quelques jours
Cyril hein vous avez vu la presse à mon
avis comme tout le monde j'ai priori
lundi matin on a eu une visite une
descente de la police chez Nadia pour
relever que tout le monde a été très
courtois c'est très bien passé ils ont
demandé de préparer ses affaires et
finalement elle a fini par quitter les
lieux actuellement elle est logée dans
un petit hôtel à quelques centaines de
mètres dans l'habiter avant c'est une
petite charmant qui ne permet pas
d'accueillir sa fille mais c'était une
solution provisoire qui lui permet pour
l'instant Nadia elle peut pas prendre
elle est où votre fille alors d'ailleurs
chez son frère d'accord pour l'instant
dire c'est une solution un peu de brique
et de broc mais finalement aujourd'hui
elle est pas dehors on a eu
dernièrement cette décision du tribunal
administratif on comptait beaucoup
dessus finalement le tribunal n'a pas
accordé la suspension l'addition du
préfet et aujourd'hui finalement
la police est intervenue du matin chez
Nadia depuis deux jours aujourd'hui elle
est dans ce petit hôtel pas loin de où
elle habitait avant ça c'est compliqué
j'ai vu quelques vidéos quelques photos
de l'endroit où elle vivait aujourd'hui
on est sur une petite chambre une
dizaine de mètres carrés c'est pas
évident pour elle c'est compliqué mais
j'allais dire il y a une décision qui
est intervenue pour l'instant la
respecte c'est le numéro de la
République en attendant un logement
social en attendant un logement qui peut
être aussi social mais un logement c'est
vrai alors vous dites vous respectez la
décision pour l'instant ça veut dire
si on revient rapidement sur ce que
j'avais évoqué lors de mon dernier
passage on a le 20 octobre
on a le 20 octobre le Gex c'est juste de
l'exécution moi j'estime encore une fois
j'ai vraiment confiance à cette
procédure aujourd'hui la procédure dans
sa globalité est nulle si vous voulez
l'audience qu'on a eu la semaine
dernière c'est une audience qui ne
servait non pas annuler la totalité de
la procédure mais simplement un
suspendre la décision du préfet
d'envoyer la force publique donc ça ne
remettait pas en cause la procédure du
tout c'était simplement de mettre une
alerte en disant clairement à la
magistrate finalement il y a une vraie
difficulté sur cette procédure-là
attendons le 20 octobre on ne sera pas
dans la trêve hivernale le 20 octobre on
a une audience qui va se présenter
devant le juge d'exécution je l'avais
clairement expliqué dans l'enfant pour
moi j'estime que la signification de
cette décision n'existe pas qu'il faut
re signifiait la décision et pour moi
aujourd'hui si on va au bout de ma
logique on est dans quelque chose qui
est relativement grave puisqu'on a pour
moi une violation de domicile d'accord
puisque
aujourd'hui si vous voulez c'est une
violation domicile pour moi en attendant
l'audience du 20 octobre en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on va plaider le 20 octobre
et la sanction à cette violation
domicile ça serait potentiellement la
réintégration la demande de
réintégration
c'est c'est pas moi qui fait des lois
est-ce qu'à un moment il faut pas que le
bon sens l'emporte non mais non mais
juste vous êtes un très bon avocat mais
vous avez été retoqué une première fois
là vous attendez une ultime audience
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas que Nadia
plutôt cherche avec les autorités
préfectorales puisqu'ils ont
l'obligation de lui trouver un logement
et ce qu'il faut pas maintenant se
tourner vers l'avenir plutôt que de
vouloir
réutiliser illégalement le logement
précédent
bichon je vais me permettre d'abord de
vous répondre peut-être
je pense que c'est une vraie
méconnaissance totale de la procédure
qui vous fait dire ça d'accord on n'a
pas été retoqué du tout on a pas obtenu
la suspension de la décision du préfet
d'envoyer la force publique il n'est pas
question du fond d'un procédure
simplement sur cette décision là du
préfet d'envoyer la force publique
aujourd'hui très bien l'exercice estimé
qu'aucune liberté fondamentale de Nadia
d'accord n'avait été en frein ça ne
remet pas du tout en cause le fond de la
procédure qui sera plaidé le 20 octobre
prochain d'accord donc aujourd'hui soyez
une mauvaise foi de l'autre fois
excusez-moi soyez une vraie
méconnaissance d'un procédure parce que
aujourd'hui encore une fois de me
reprocher de faire mon travail c'est
compliqué j'entends parfaitement qu'à un
moment donné il faut retrouver la raison
mais qu'il faut entre la raison et Nadia
et sur la même et sur la même longueur
d'onde que moi si vous voulez on sait
qu'il y a des lois c'est le aujourd'hui
j'allais dire elles doivent servir aux
propriétaires et au locataires mais elle
ne veut pas moins servir au locataire
d'accord voilà voilà un petit peu l'état
d'esprit dans lequel on est l'apaisement
on a caisse et je l'ai déjà Cyril tout à
l'heure cette décision de justice on
respecte cette décision mais on écarte
pas pour autant cette possibilité le 20
octobre et revenir encore dans l'appart
si alors on a d'abord véritablement
discuté c'est pas vraiment son choix
aujourd'hui si vous voulez elle veut que
ça s'arrête voilà aujourd'hui ça
s'arrête un peu plus mais alors elle est
soulagée elle est soulagée mais de
l'autre côté elle est dans la rue parce
que là aujourd'hui elle a une solution
provisoire de 15 jours mais dans 15
jours il y a plus rien d'accord voilà la
réalité aujourd'hui
vous êtes pas maître vous êtes juste un
homme est-ce que vous pensez une poche
[Rires]
je ne peux pas je ne veux pas que ce
soit le maître qui parle ce soir
l'avocat avec tous ces éléments de
langage certes très habile l'homme vous
trouvez pas juste que c'est
extraordinaire que ces retraités et puis
et puis rentrer chez eux enfin alors que
ça fait deux ans et demi qui sont dans
leur camping-car je vais encore une fois
vous répondre non mais je veux juste
l'avocats
d'abord j'ai pas l'impression d'utiliser
j'allais dire des des rang de jambes ou
quoi que ce soit je parle peut-être un
peu sur la procédure quand même donc moi
je veux pas de procédure là
vous me parlez je vais je vais je vais
vous répondre c'est formidable tout le
monde on est tous heureux aujourd'hui
les garçons et retrouver leur logement
bon ben c'est formidable mais évidemment
mais attendez mais est-ce que vous
pensez est-ce que vous pensez
suffisamment sous pour penser le
contraire à un moment donné quand vous
êtes retraités que vous avez travaillé
toute votre vie que vous voulez
bénéficier du fruit de votre travail que
vous voulez réintégrer le logement que
le vôtre mais bien évidemment qu'il faut
que ce soit possible mais c'est pas un
Nadia de porter le fardeau d'une loi qui
est mal faite aujourd'hui avec
l'influence qu'elle a votre je pense
qu'il serait peut-être plus judicieux
d'aller voir je suis pas les politiques
d'aller voir le législateur en disant
mais ce qui se passe c'est scandaleux
parce qu'aujourd'hui pour récupérer un
logement il faut des années parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand on est locataire
bon on a peut-être des droits qui sont
peut-être incohérents quand les
propriétaires on a peut-être aussi des
droits qui sont incohérents c'est ça le
vrai débat le vrai débat aujourd'hui
le débat aujourd'hui parce que des
nageurs aujourd'hui vous l'avez sur TPMP
c'est magnifique de l'avoir aujourd'hui
mais des Nadia il y en a des milliers en
France donc aujourd'hui c'est l'endroit
qui porte c'est peut-être la mienne mais
des Nadia mais il y en a aujourd'hui en
France des milliers donc bien évidemment
que je suis d'accord avec vous il faut
que ces gens-là à un moment donné
retrouve le logement mais il y a une loi
il faut que la loi soit la même Nadia
vous êtes dans quelle disposition
aujourd'hui ben disposition ça a été
très violent très violent je vous avoue
l'humiliation la police est venue chez
moi je remercie particulièrement la
police de l'Estaque pour cette
bienveillance oui mais quand vous avez
tous un domicile aujourd'hui et comme
vous vous levez le matin pour vous dire
vous allez prendre vous avez pris la
décision de boucler
tout le dimanche et que vous vous dites
je vais aller voir la police et leur
déposer les clés et qu'à 7h on toque et
que vous voyez je les ai pas comptés je
vous avoue huit personnes
vous venez juste de vous réveiller c'est
une violence alors je compatis encore je
suis heureuse pour me les épaules Garcia
mais cette violence que j'ai subi
j'ai été comme une criminelle et moins
que rien sur une place publique lynchée
et ça a continué dans la journée puisque
j'ai été harcelé par les journalistes
j'ai été suivie par les journalistes les
époux Garcia ont fait appel au
journaliste et donc aujourd'hui c'est
pour ça que je suis là que je vous ai
demandé de venir car même à mon pire
ennemi sérieusement je ne le souhaite
pas j'ai pas du tout
dans un camping-car
de violence ce mot est indigne
que j'apprécie pour autant
est venu s'enquérir de la santé de Nadia
à la sortie de votre de votre émission
en lui disant que il faut aller trouver
une solution donc
encore une fois c'est une méconnaissance
totale du dossier chère Madame
excusez-moi madame
de quelqu'un qui nous dit que c'est
violent qu'elle a vécu une matinée
quelque chose alors que les autres ça
fait deux ans et demi à leur âge ils en
sont malades je ne veux je ne peux pas
entendre ça et je pense qu'on est
beaucoup à ne pas pouvoir entendre ça
c'est ça que je reproche à Nadia moi je
souhaite une seule chose c'est que votre
fille et vous vous ayez un toit vous
vous disiez correctement évidemment je
suis une femme je suis pas une avocate
maintenant ce mot là moi je trouve
indigne excusez-moi excusez-moi je pense
qu'encore une fois c'est de
méconnaissance totale du dossier de le
13 septembre 2022 vos deux ans vous avez
compris comment alors je veux bien qu'à
un moment donné les dates ne comptent
pas ici je veux bien que finalement les
actes de procédure qui sont pas bons ça
n'intéresse personne le 13 septembre
2022 on est aujourd'hui le 5 le 6
octobre ou voilà enfin le 8 peut-être
octobre aujourd'hui excusez-moi de vous
dire ça vos deux ans vous les trouvez
comment si vous m'expliquer ça pas du
tout je sais pas ce que je suis en train
de vous dire que lorsque vous me dit que
ça fait 2 ans et demi que sont dans leur
camping-car moi je vous réponds
simplement que si cette procédure était
correctement montée ce que je ne crois
pas dans le meilleur des cas si cette
procédure était correctement montée elle
devrait partir le 13 septembre ce que
j'estime qui n'est pas le cas c'est un
gestimant plus qu'elle est mal montée où
vous trouvez excusez-moi de d'assister
deux ans et demi entre le 13 septembre
2022 et aujourd'hui si jamais vous
arrivez à me faire rentrer deux ans et
demi dans cette période on est d'accord
chez Madame donc ils ont vécu par
plaisir dans leur camping-car alors
qu'ils sont propriétaires bon moi je
veux dire c'est qu'au-delà de la
procédure il faut reconnaître aussi que
cette dame elle a été dans la machine à
laver médiatique et heureusement que il
y a cette émission et les chroniqueurs
pour que enfin les institutions de
l'État
gagner du temps
Nadège justement alors aujourd'hui vous
êtes venu dans l'émission qu'est-ce que
vous voudriez dire
qu'est-ce que vous voulez comment vous
voulez que ça évolue
moins de droits que j'ai moins de droits
que tout le monde quand je vous entends
dire deux ans et demi si on part si vous
connaissez le dossier je ne suis pas
avocat je connais mon histoire je
connais ma vie je sais ce qui s'est
passé je sais avec qui j'ai signé ce
bail madame si vous vous connaissiez
vraiment le dossier vous ne parlez pas
de deux ans et demi vous ne pariez pas
en fait de limite vous ne parlez que de
mes obligations et
aucunement de mes droits j'ai des droits
vous comprenez ma fille a des droits je
ne me je ne suis pas venu ici pour être
demandé votre pitié ou quoi que ce soit
j'ai toujours retravaillé j'ai toujours
assumé mes deux enfants ce que je
demande c'est juste d'avoir été respecté
respecté mes droits c'est tout
simplement ils ont des droits j'ai eu
des droits tout simplement je suis
humaine autant aujourd'hui le
l'acharnement médiatique qui a eu ce
n'est pas moi moi j'ai pris un avocat
j'ai une assurance de protection
juridique on m'a conseillé on est dans
un pays de droit on est bien d'accord
aujourd'hui le droit est pas forcément
donc tout simplement vous voilà pardon
dans le déroulé en fait des événements
et d'après votre logique et d'après vos
combats pour vous il serait plus
confortable de réintégrer le logement
plutôt que d'en trouver un nouveau c'est
ça c'est pas ce que j'ai dit vous m'avez
la question
vous avez quand même un avocat donc vous
vous battez pour quelque chose pour vos
droits donc du coup pour vous ce serait
plus positif de réintégrer quand même le
logement qui vous est dû parce que sinon
vous seriez pas là plutôt que de
retrouver un nouveau logement pour avoir
une nouvelle vie et donc ce qui veut
dire que c'est charmants retraités ben
retour à la case départ chez eux et ben
c'est leur camping-car c'est ça
l'exprimé où j'ai peut-être pas été
compréhensible
on était content que vous veniez voilà
vous avez invité la première fois et on
est on va sur on joue le jeu et c'est
normal que vous soyez là pour faire
passer un message aussi alors je vous
réponds je vous expliquais ce qui ce
qu'aujourd'hui la loi me permettait
d'accord si vous avez écouté mon propos
jusqu'au bout je vous disais que pour
l'instant ce n'est rien décidé et que
aujourd'hui Nadia elle est plutôt
soulagée aujourd'hui que ça se passe
comme ça et que je ne pense pas qu'elle
aille jusqu'à ça mais est-ce que vous
vous rendez compte que lorsque vous
rentrez dans un domicile d'accord d'une
personne qui a un bail alors que
j'explique au préfet en amont qui a une
difficulté sur la signification de la
décision que j'explique cela à
l'huissier d'accord en amont tu es une
difficulté soit significat que tout le
monde se [ __ ] totalement de cette
explication qui vont quand même lundi
matin chez Nadia avec le risque qui le
leur excusez-moi c'est pas moi qui le
prend le risque c'est eux qui le prenne
d'accord c'est pas moi qui venais la loi
c'est pas moi qui met 7 sanction là
c'est la langue qui le propose alors
aucun cas je vous explique que Nadia a
choisi cette option vous me demandez ce
que la loi prévoit je vous explique ce
que la loi prévoit alors c'est vrai que
dans l'émission ça fait des années qu'on
dit que les lois sont mal faites et ce
serait bien qu'elle change du coup vous
pensez pas jusque votre bon sens
pourrait faire que en deux ans et demi
vous pouvez trouver un nouveau logement
pour que ces gens n'ont pas besoin de
retourner dans leur camping-cars alors
alors je vous je vous donne raison et je
suis d'accord avec vous finalement on
aurait pu il y a pas lieu d'être en fait
vous avez pas besoin d'être là avec des
agences immobilières soit des logements
sociaux soit un logement tout court un
petit F2 c'est très bien avec avec votre
fille c'est parfait
enfants j'ai donc
en fait
je ne suis pas venu débattre sur un T2
T1 T3 c'est ça devait rester en fait
tout simplement entre l'agence et moi et
la justice aujourd'hui je ne vais pas
décider de médiatiser les choses j'ai
été expulsé un moment ou un autre je
devais quitter le logement les démarches
je ne vais pas les déballer devant toute
la France ou devant tout le monde après
2 ans et demi je sais ce que j'ai fait
ça c'est vous qui le dites vous n'avez
pas mon dossier de en fait vous n'avez
aucun dossier de deux ans et demi
puisque le congé il a été donné le 16
mai je devais quitter le on remet des
dates le 17 février 2021 je devais
quitter les lieux le 17 février 2021
donc maintenant
on va dire moi je suis soulagé peut-être
aussi d'avoir quitté
même le remercier puisque même mes
voisins à qui je disais bonjour tout le
monde m'a tourné le dos vraiment je
lance un appel pourquoi vouloir revenir
là bas
pourquoi vouloir revenir dans
l'appartement alors est-ce que non mais
c'est ce que non
la loi prévoit c'est d'accord donc vous
les trouvez autre chose Nadia vous en
êtes où aujourd'hui dans vos recherches
alors
mes recherches
il
entre lundi et aujourd'hui il y a pas de
voyez le lavabo vous avez commencé lundi
à chercher madame
vous aurez plus vous trouver un
appartement
je parle du départ de l'expulsion madame
je pars du départ la dernière fois que
vous avez cherché activement depuis des
mois
il y a une espèce de contradiction enfin
en tout cas
dans le processus je viens en fait pour
en fait être contré sur ma vie en fait
moi je connais mon histoire je vais je
n'ai pas que ça à faire à monter sur
Paris j'ai bien d'autres choses à faire
si vous voulez aujourd'hui en fait la
problématique aujourd'hui c'est que ça a
été médiatisé et ça prend une ampleur
sur ma vie sur la vie de mes enfants de
mes proches de mes amis de mon travail
aussi faut pas oublier mettre aussi un
cabinet qui doit qui doit faire
tourner il a peut-être délaissé
humainement pour moi justement c'est
puisque il a de toutes sortes de clients
il a oui quand vous parlez en tant que
être humain mettre ses rousses à
délaisser aussi même sa famille pour moi
l'idée aujourd'hui si vous voulez c'est
qu'il faut sortir de là
on voit pas aujourd'hui il faut sortir
de là aujourd'hui encore une fois je
vais je vais je vais essayer d'aller au
but il y a ce que la loi prévoit il y a
ce qu'on a déjà vu je pense qu'il faut
aussi avoir un comportement à un moment
donné un petit peu humain et éviter
d'être comme une meute en allant
rechercher la difficulté chez elle vous
voyez parfaitement comme en difficulté
je pense qu'aujourd'hui elle a besoin de
temps elle a besoin de se retrouver elle
a besoin d'un logement on va l'aider
mais de la meilleure des façons et
est-ce que disait Tony tout à l'heure
c'est quelque chose de très juste où
sont les pouvoirs publics finalement la
tête de Nadia tout le monde l'a vu sur
il faut il y a aucun politique personne
n'est logement pour un logement social
pour les bailleurs sociaux pour les
intervenants au niveau de la musique
se retrouve à la
de l'aider de trouver un logement pour
elle et ses enfants merci merci en tout
cas merci aussi et Nadia et on va
essayer voilà de vous aider aussi parce
que voilà on a pas envie aussi de voir
de voir des gens malheureux voilà dans
cette émission on est content et Maryse
on a pas envie voilà que ça ça vous
[ __ ] voilà dans l'embarré et vos
enfants aussi sur ton pense à votre
fille surtout qui vivait avec vous merci
en tout cas d'avoir merci beaucoup